und der Untersuchungs der
Untersuchungsausschuss Warburg Bank
meine Damen und Herren der steht jetzt
hier auf dem Plan das ist der nächste
Tagesordnungspunkt die cdu/csu möchte
die Einsetzung des zweiten
Untersuchungsausschusses in der 20
Wahlperiode da geht es eben um die
Warburg Bank wie andere Institute war
die Privatbank Warburg in inzwischen
höchst richterlich als illegal
eingestuften cum-ex-geschäfte verwickelt
dabei schoben Investoren Aktienpakete
rund um den Dividenden Stichtag hin und
her ziel war es sich von den
Finanzämtern Kapitalertragssteuer
zurückerstanden zu lassen die nie
gezahlt worden waren es handelt sich um
das womöglich umfassendste System der
Steuerhinterziehung in der deutschen
Wirtschaftsgeschichte der Staat wurde um
Milliarden geprellt die Union beantragt
nun auf Bundesebene einen
Untersuchungsausschuss auch weil der
Bundeskanzler damals die erste
Bürgermeister von Hamburg hier ein
wichtiger Zeuge werden wird genauso wie
in Untersuchungsausschuss der bereits zu
diesem Sachverhalt in Hamburg
seit anderthalb Jahren tagt Matthias
Mittelberg wird jetzt begründen warum es
jetzt auch einen Untersuchungsausschuss
auf Bundesebene geben soll meine Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen wir hätten uns diesen Antrag
auf einen Untersuchungsausschuss
Steueraffäre Scholz Warburg sparen
können wenn zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt ihr
heutiger Herr Bundeskanzler und frühere
erste Bürgermeister von Hamburg hier in
diesem Parlament irgendwann mal ehrlich
Rede und Antwort zu dem Thema gestanden
hätte
das ist leider nicht der Fall gewesen
ihr Bundeskanzler ist ohnehin bekannt
ich sage das mal so vorsichtig für
reduzierte Kommunikation wir haben in
diesem Thema festgestellt dass es 0
Kommunikation gab wir haben ihn
schriftlich befragt
wir haben ihn in den Finanzausschuss
eingeladen und wir haben ihn hier auch
in der Kanzler Befragung zu diesem Thema
gestellt in der kanzlerbefragung fand er
es noch besonders cool dass er um unsere
Fragen locker drumherum geschwurmelt ist
ich sage das so deutlich so war es
nämlich und deswegen gibt es nur einen
Weg dieses Thema jetzt sorgfältig zu
untersuchen nämlich die Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses
der heutige Bundeskanzler hat damals
selber gesagt die cum-ex-geschäfte waren
eine Riesenschweinerei ihm sei völlig
schleierhaft wie man das je habe für
legal halten können
gleichzeitig war Hamburg unter der
politischen Verantwortung von Olaf
Scholz 2016 das einzige Bundesland in
dieser Republik das einzige von 16
Bundesländern dass diese zu Unrecht
erstatteten Steuergelder von der
warburgbank nicht zurückgefordert hat
ich sag's noch mal das einzige der
Bundesländer und wir werden in diesen
Zusammenhang fragen wer ist dafür in
Hamburg politisch verantwortlich gewesen
dass diese Gelder nicht zurück verlangt
wurden
sie sagen immer wieder wenn wir über
dieses Thema diskutieren es sei ja
bisher nichts rausgekommen es hätte sich
nichts ergeben tatsächlich ist der
Tatort mittlerweile übersetzt mit
Indizien mit Spuren die alle darauf
hindeuten dass in diesem Fall politische
Einflussnahme auf die konkrete
Entscheidung stattgefunden hat erst gab
es in der Hamburger Behörde die
Rechtsauffassung die Gelder mussten
zurückgefordert werden dann gab es eine
ganze Reihe von Gesprächen mit den Chefs
der Bank mit Politikern der
Sozialdemokraten in Hamburg man kann sie
fast gar nicht alle aufzählen und zum
Schluss eben auch Gespräche mit
bürgermeister Olaf Scholz unmittelbar
nach diesen Gesprächen hat dann die
Behörde in Hamburg ihre Rechtsauffassung
geändert und an dem Tag als man in der
Behörde eine andere Entscheidung
getroffen hat hat die zuständige
Finanzbeamtin eine private
whatsapp-nachricht an ihre Freundin
geschickt und hat geschrieben ein
teuflischer Plan ist heute aufgegangen
wir können uns alle überlegen was ein
ordnungsgemäßer Verwaltungsvollzug ist
aber wenn ich Beamten bin und will
irgendwie eine ordnungsgemäß
Verwaltungsentscheidung beschreiben dann
würde ich das nicht teuflischer Plan
nennen das löst reichlich Fragen aus
und ich sage Ihnen noch folgendes
ihr Herr Bundeskanzler hat ja zu Recht
immer darauf hingewiesen er habe in
diesem Fall keinen Einfluss nehmen
dürfen und habe das auch nicht getan
wenn ich keinen Einfluss nehmen darf auf
eine Verwaltungsentscheidung das
betrifft viele die in der Verwaltung
führend sind dass sie in dem konkreten
Fall keinen Einfluss nehmen dürfen dann
sage ich dass dem betreffenden der mich
darum nachsucht der mich darum bittet
dem sage ich das einmal dann führe ich
ein Gespräch hier hat Olaf Scholz ein
Gespräch geführt mit den Chefs der
Warburg Bank eine Stunde lang in seinem
Amtszimmer acht Wochen später hat er
sich dann noch mal mit denen
zusammengesetzt noch mal für eine Stunde
in seinem am Zimmer und dann hat er zwei
Wochen später hinter dem Chef Denker
noch hinterher telefoniert und hat ihm
gesagt ich kenne übrigens noch einen der
sich auch nicht einmischen darf und das
ist mein finanz
inventure und an den schickst du jetzt
bitte deine Unterlagen und dann wirst du
eine adäquate Entscheidung bekommen das
muss man sich vorstellen wie logisch ist
denn dieser Vorgang wie blöd müssen denn
diese Bänker gewesen sein dass Olaf
Scholz ihn dreimal hintereinander
stundenlang erklären musste dass er sich
in diesem Fall nicht einmischen darf
nein wir sind an einem völlig anderen
Punkt bei dieser Beweislage
wird in jeder Jurist sagen hier gilt
jetzt das Prinzip Umkehr der Beweislast
wenn in all diesen Gesprächen jetzt
angeblich nicht über die warburgbank und
die steuerrückforderungen gesprochen
wurde was ja der Bankchef olearius in
seinem Tagebuch exakt so niedergelegt
hat wenn das dann nicht der Fall war
dann würden wir aber gerne das Olaf
Scholz und jetzt mal mitteilt worüber
wurde denn gesprochen über das
Radwegenetz in Hamburg über die
Fütterung der Schwäne auf der
Außenalster oder was sind denn die
Themen gewesen nein jetzt sind wir an
dem Punkt wo der Bundeskanzler zu
erklären hat was jetzt Gegenstand dieser
Gespräche war
dieses Verfahren diese Sache ist
brandaktuell denn der relevante Banker
der Bankchef olearius der Warburg Bank
ist vor einer Woche ist die Anklage
gegen ihn zugelassen worden beim
Landgericht Bonn übrigens auch so ein
Fall wo die Hamburger Staatsanwaltschaft
meinte da gibt es ja nicht mal
Verdachtsmomente da muss man nichts
machen das hat die Staatsanwaltschaft in
Köln ganz anders gesehen die haben den
angeklagt jetzt steht der in Bonn vor
Gericht wegen
280 Millionen Steuerhinterziehung um
diesen Fall geht es und um die Frage ob
auf diesen Fall auf diesen Sachverhalt
auch politisch Einfluss genommen wurde
und das wird der kernerklärung des
Untersuchungsausschusses sein herzlichen
Dank
die Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses ist ein
Minderheitenrecht hier im Deutschen
Bundestag ein Viertel der Abgeordneten
können einen solchen
Untersuchungsausschuss beantragen der
dann zur erfolgen hat die cdu/csu
verfügt über 197 Abgeordnete 184
Unterschriften wären notwendig gewesen
die Union hat diese 197 Stimmen komplett
versammeln können insofern wird es
diesen Untersuchungsausschuss geben
Michael schrodi Sprecher für Finanzen
der SPD als nächster Redner
und Herren in Deutschland ist der Steuer
Vollzug Aufgabe der Länder
zum steuervoll Warburg Bank gibt es
deshalb seit zweieinhalb Jahren einen
Untersuchungsausschuss dort wo er
hingehört in Hamburg dort wurden alle
relevanten Zeugen vernommen alle Akten
gesichtet alle Fragen gestellt und
beantwortet das Ergebnis nach diesen
zweieinhalb Jahren ist eindeutig an all
diesen Unterstellungen ermittelt ja
keine neuen Ideen der all diesen
Unterstellungen ist nichts dran es gab
keine Verfehlungen der zuständigen
Hamburger Behörden es gab keine
politische Einflussnahme es gibt keinen
finanziellen Schaden kein Steuergeld
verloren gegangen auch wenn Ihnen das
politisch überhaupt
zur Kenntnis meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
und dennoch will die cdu/csu
nein nahezu identischen
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag
einrichten das ist offensichtlich der
cdu/cs so geht es nicht um
Erkenntnisgewinn sondern reine
Stimmungsmache gegen den Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz
beim
intens stellt sich schonen die Frage was
wollen sie eigentlich wirklich Neues
untersuchen da gibt es nämlich wenig bis
gar nichts auch in ihren Antrag nicht um
es an drei Beispielen konkret zu machen
die Union will vermeintlich klären ob es
eine politische Einflussnahme auf ein
Steuerverfahren in Hamburg gaben der
parlamentarische Untersuchungsausschuss
in Hamburg hat sich damit intensiv
beschäftigt und auch Antworten geliefert
ich zitiere als änderungsstütze für sie
aus dem Hamburger Abendblatt am
18.06.2021 die frühere Leiterin des
Hamburger Finanzamt für Großunternehmen
hat im parlamentarischen
Untersuchungsausschuss am Freitagabend
betont das ist keine politische
Einflussnahme gaben wen und was wollen
Sie dazu eigentlich noch Fragen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
Beispiel 2 sie wollen vermeintlich
wissen wer Verantwortung trägt zu
schreiben ist für etwaige politische
Entscheidungen mit erheblichen
finanziellen Schaden alleine es gab und
gibt keinen finanziellen Schatz das
wissen sie auch ganz genau es gab auch
nie die Gefahr einer Verjährung auch die
gab es nicht es gab im Hamburger
Finanzamt die Frage inwieweit die
Rückforderung der Warburg Bank 2016
rechtlich
durchsetzbar ist und um diese
Entscheidung die Gelder vorerst nicht
zurückzufordern der damalige
Staatsanwalt in Köln die Ermittlungen
gegen die warburgbahn führte war über
diese Vorgänge informiert und betonte im
Hamburger Untersuchungsausschuss er sei
mit der Entscheidung der Hamburger
Finanzbehörden Zitat absolut davor
gewesen nach der juristischen Klärung
durch das Landgericht wolle März 2020
hat die Hamburger Steuerverwaltung auch
die Gelder sofort zurückgefordert sogar
mit finanziellen gewinnen weil es
entsprechende Verzugszinsen sogar noch
gab es ist schon bekannt es ist alles
schon auch in den Zeitungen wen oder was
wollen sie auch hier zu überhaupt noch
Fragen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren und zuletzt Beispiel drei sie
wollen wissen ob es vermeintliche
Widersprüche in den Aussagen von Olaf
Scholz gab also hierzu liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen waren in der letzten Woche
am Freitag 12 Bundestagsabgeordnete im
Hamburger Untersuchungsausschuss die ist
Fett vom 14 April 2023 schreibt die
Befragung zur Befragung erstreckt sich
an diesem Freitag über mehrere Stunden
die Eindrücke der Zeugen decken sich in
wesentlichen Punkten Scholz habe im
Finanzausschuss betont das zum Fall
alles bekannt sein über die
Berichterstattung hinaus könne er keine
Auskunft geben auch die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft zieht keinen
an Verdacht wegen vermeintlicher
Falschaussage von Olaf Scholz ergo
hier nicht kein Widerspruch wen oder was
wollen Sie hier eigentlich noch Fragen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
es könnte noch weiteres solcher in
Fragen gekleideter Unterstellungen aus
ihrem Antrag aufgezählt werden die
längst aufgeklärt und widerlegt sind
übrigens zu der Frage Herr Mittelberg ob
ich ihn tatsächlich um Erkenntnis
gewinnen geht
es gab 2020
drei Sitzungen des Finanzausschusses des
Deutschen Bundestages in den Olaf Scholz
genauso dem Thema Rede und Antwort stand
Herr Hauer Herr Hauer
siegerien sich hier als Chef Aufklärer
damals hatten sie die große Gelegenheit
Fragen zu stellen und was war in der
Sitzung am dritten vierten Herr Hauer
haben sie keine einzige Frage gestellt
in der Sitzung
und am 09.09 Hauer sagen sie selber
haben sie keine einzige Frage gestellt
ihr Interesse an dem Thema und das ist
ihre Kolleginnen was sehr begrenzt bis
dann Olaf Scholz zum Kanzlerkandidaten
der SPD ausgerufen wurde und dann wurde
es für sie ein Thema ein politisches
Thema und seitdem wiederholen sie
falsche längst wieder legt
Unterstellungen um Stimmung zu machen
damals gegen den Kanzlerkandidaten der
SPD jetzt gegen den Bundeskanzler und es
wird Ihnen wieder nicht gelingen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
und noch zu einer letzten relevanten
Frage
das Instrument Untersuchungsausschuss
ist ein wichtiges Element der
parlamentarischen Kontrolle der
Bundesregierung und ein wichtiges
Minderheitenrecht Opposition es ist
daher übrigens wenig geeignet für
politische Instrumentalisierung und
Klamauk dieses Recht auf Untersuchung
hat jedoch auch seine
verfassungsrechtlichen Grenzen wenn sich
wie in ihrem Antrag überwiegende Teile
des
untersuchungsauftrags auf das Handeln
der Freien und Hansestadt Hamburg
beziehen dann drängt sich geradezu die
Frage auf inwieweit Teile ihres
untersuchungsauftrags und die Fragen
unserer von unserer Verfassung überhaupt
noch gedeckt sind denn die regierungs-
und Verwaltungskontrolle des Parlaments
ein wichtiges recht wie zum Beispiel
Untersuchungsausschuss hat das Verhalten
der eigenen Exekutive zum Gegenstand der
Bundestag kontrolliert die
Bundesregierung die Regierung in der
Gebietskörperschaft unterliegender
Kontrolle ihrer Parlamente sowohl des
übrigens auch bei der Einsetzung des
cum-ex-untersuchungsausschusses 2016 von
cdu/csu und SPD gemeinsam auch genauso
formuliert ich mache es ihnen mal
griffiger die maskendealer Fähre des
bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten Markus
Söder wird deshalb nicht im Deutschen
Bundestag zu den Bayerischen Landtag
aufgeklärt da gibt es übrigens mehr zu
untersuchen und zu holen als hier
es lässt sich also abschließend sagen in
die weil die Ausweitung des
Untersuchungsverfahrens auf rein
Hamburger Angelegenheit ein
verfassungsrechtlichen Eingriff in deren
staatliche Hoheit bedeutet scheint mir
die allererste Frage zu sein die der
Geschäftsordnungsausschuss den wir heute
den Antrag der cocs überweisen wird
klären müssen meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren allen weiteren Schritten
sehen wir gelassen mit großen Vertrauen
entgegen vielen Dank
bevor ich den nächsten Redner Aufrufe
oder die nächste nee den nächsten
Rechner gibt es eine kurze Intervention
aus der afd-fraktion
Herr Kollege sie haben das Wort
entschuldige ich glaube auch das werden
mir was sie hier eben gesagt haben im
Untersuchungsausschuss klären denn ihnen
sollte bekannt sein und ich habe ja als
Zeuge am Freitag ausgesagt und bin gut
vernetzt mit den Kollegen in Hamburg das
nach wie vor sie sprechen von Schaden
sei nicht entstanden und sie spielen
dieses narrativ um mich auch dass die
Zinsen ja ein Gewinn wären ist Ihnen
bekannt oder haben Sie wieder besseren
Wissens in ihrer Rede eben behauptet ist
vollständig bezahlt wurde denn in
Hamburg und dem Untersuchungsausschuss
ist klar geworden dass immer noch nicht
vollständig die Zinsen da Warburg Bank
entsprechend die gezahlt werden mussten
auf die 47 Millionen erstattet worden
sind oder haben sie da jetzt auch
partielle Amnesia Bundeskanzler
Herr Schrode sie dürfen
antworten sie dürfen
sehr geehrter Gottschalk ich habe mein
Ausführungen von vorher eigentlich
nichts noch mal dazu zu setzen denn es
ist klar geworden in meinen Ausführungen
und das geht jetzt gerade hier
wir haben den Vorwurf es gäbe eine ein
verjähren lassen von Rückforderungen der
warburgbank das habe ich erwähnt ist
falsches Behauptung und es ist falsch
auch die Behauptung des steht im Antrag
der cocsu hier
dass es finanziellen Schaden gab und ich
habe deutlich gemacht und das kann man
nachlesen das ist schlichtweg falsch die
Rückforderungen sind verlangt sie sind
eingezogen und sie sind das ist mein
Kenntnisstand und so können Sie auch
gerne lesen sind inklusive der Zinsen
weil es gibt Verzugszinsen auch gezahlt
worden insofern ist das was die cdu/csu
in ihrem Antrag formuliert hat
schlichtweg falsch das habe ich zum
Ausdruck gebracht
[Applaus]
guten Tag allerseits stefan hat das Wort
für die AFD
ja und stefanten als der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der AFD
Mitglied im Rechtsausschuss
fange ich an kann ich anfangen also
meine Damen und Herren frau Präsidentin
natürlich auch meine Damen und Herren
die CDU sitzt ihren ersten eigenen
Untersuchungsausschuss ein und was sie
nach großem Tamtam und großspuriger
Ankündigung nun vorlegt ist mehr als
dünn sechseinhalb Seiten davon
anderthalb Seiten alleine Namen ich muss
jetzt sagen mit fünf Seiten
untersuchungsauftragter kommen Sie bei
uns nicht weit Opposition müssen sie
noch lernen wir sitzen direkt neben
ihnen rufen Sie einfach bei uns an und
wir zeigen Ihnen wie das geht nicht
desto trotz will man sich nun den
mutmaßlichen Lügengeschichten und oder
der zunehmenden Amnesie Anfällen des
Kanzlers schade übrigens dass er nicht
da ist vielleicht hatte den Termin ja
vergessen heute also jedenfalls das ist
unsere Sicht in Ordnung und bedarf eine
Aufklärung denn wer möchte schon von
jemanden regiert werden der entweder
rätselhaft vergesslich ist oder einfach
lügt ohne roter zu werden als er bereits
ist meine Damen und Herren der Begriff
ist rumscholzen ist inzwischen zunächst
im deutschen Sprachgebrauch verankert er
steht für sorgfältige und langfristige
Planung und Politik Ankündigung aber das
Gegenteil dann machen für ausweicheln
für wecklöcheln für Bürger auslachen für
nicht reagieren und für auf
Gedächtnisverlust verweisen wie Joe
Biden für arme wir sind halt in
Deutschland wie kann so ein Mann die
kann ein solche Person Deutschland
überhaupt regieren ein Land das von
einer großen Krise in die andere
schlittert und gesteuert wird wie kann
so ein Mensch an der Spitze unseres
Staates stehen die Zeitschrift Cicero
hat die Antwort dazu in Form einer Frage
und die lautet wie konnte jemand mit so
wenig Anstand und Begabung ins
Bundeskanzleramt kommen ich verrate sie
es ist zum einen seine Schuld zu matt
Aura und seine Konkurrenten waren ja
auch mehr als blass vor Merkel wollte
oder sollte nicht mehr kannst da
Kandidat
lächelte sich ins Abseits meiner Sicht
der flugkatastrophe in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Söder versteckte
sich strikte sich in Intrigen aus denen
ja nicht mehr herauskamen und der
heutige Oppositionsführer Herr Merz
sitzt ja da ist mit seiner
blackrock-verstrickung ja auch als
Bundeskanzler kaum zumutbare Blackrock
muss man wissen der März weiß es er
lächelt schon black OP muss man wissen
ein Investment eine investment-gruppe
mit einem verwalteten Vermögen von 10
Billionen Euro etwa zweieinhalb Mal so
viel wie Deutschland überhaupt als
Bruttosozialprodukt erwirtschaftete märz
das lässt nichts gutes erwarten auf die
Person die demnächst Einfluss auf
deutsche Politik hier in Deutschland
nehmen sollen es vor allem nichts Gutes
auch noch Wolfgang Schäuble ist ja ein
Gedächtnis mit dem Geldkoffer und in
100.000 Mark die nie geklärt wurden also
da schwingt sich jemand zum Ankläger auf
der einen zum Anleger auf der eigentlich
auf die Anklagebank gehört meine Damen
und Geldkoffer Korruption man denke an
die Corona Gewinne und die Masken die
dabei CDU und csu-skandale wohin man
schaut und der Herr Scholz erster
Bürgermeister von Hamburg der schon beim
G20 Gipfel im Jahr 2017 seine Stadt in
Schutt und Asche hat legen lassen hängt
in diesem Sumpf mittendrin noch
interessanter wird natürlich dadurch
dass in diesem
Warburger Bank Sumpf jetzt auch noch
Matthias Döpfner auftauchte wissen das
ist der
Springer-Chef der uns aus deutsche gerne
als Faschisten oder Kommunisten bestimmt
und gerne die FDP und Herren Kubicki in
seinem Presseorganen in den Himmel und
über den grünen Klee los also ich bin
gespannt was da kommt auch her hat 60
Millionen von der Warburg Bank erhalten
bin gespannt was da noch alles so
Vorschein kommt meine Damen und Herren
es bedarf der Aufklärung aber wir haben
wesentlich größere Probleme in
Deutschland wir haben erheblichen
Schaden durch das Afghanistan Desaster
mit vielen Toten durch das
corona-desaster mit 100 Milliarden
kosten die Nord streamsprengung die
schrankenlose Einwanderung explodierende
Kriminalität Zick Milliarden kosten
durch die anwanderung das Treuhand
Desaster und das Desaster des Merkel
Regimes diese Probleme bedürfen der
Aufklärung zusätzlich das wollen sie
natürlich alle nicht sie haben alle
direkt anstecken sie wollen vertuschen
sie stürzen sich jetzt auf Olaf Scholz
und die Warburg Bank viel Spaß dabei wir
sind dabei aber meinen das ist viel viel
größere viel viel größere Anstrengungen
bedarf um Deutschland wieder auf den
rechten Weg zu bringen vielen Dank
die nächste Rednerin in der Debatte
kommt von den Bündnis grünen Katharina
Beck sie Sprecherin für Finanzen der
grünen Bundestagsfraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Liebe Unionsfraktion sie stellen einen
Antrag auf Einsetzung eines
parlamentarischen
Untersuchungsausschusses mit einem sehr
konkreten Ziel die Sachverhalte rund um
die steuerrückforderungen der
warburgbank in Hamburg im Rahmen von
cum-ex-geschäften weiter aufzuklären es
ist ihr gutes Recht als Fraktion des
Deutschen Bundestages und dem
übergeordneten Ziel des Antrags
Transparenz und lückenloses aufklären
möglicher finanzmarktkriminalität dem
kann ich viel abgewinnen und wir Grünen
treten seit vielen Jahren genau dafür
ein deshalb waren es ja auch wir Grüne
allen voran das möchte ich noch mal
erwähnen der geschätzte ehemalige
Kollege Gerhard Schick die 2016 den
ersten Untersuchungsausschuss
zukunftsinitiiert haben dadurch wurden
überhaupt erst die wichtigen
Erkenntnisse rund um die
kommex-geschäfte aufgedeckt und das
immense Ausmaß des Schadens auch die
Relevanz des Themas
überhaupt erkannt zudem konnte die
damalige personelle Unterbesetzung des
BMF oder die Einflussnahme wichtiger
finanzlobbygruppen durch diesen
Untersuchungsausschuss sichtbar gemacht
werden und mit diesen und weiteren
Erkenntnissen konnten nicht nur die
strafrechtlichen Untersuchungen sinnvoll
bearbeitet und vorbereitet werden das
Thema kam so erst auch richtig in die
Öffentlichkeit und schuf ein Bewusstsein
für das doch den sperrigen Begriff in
der Breite der Gesellschaft und vielen
Dank an dieser Stelle noch mal
fraktionsübergreifend für alle an die
gute Arbeit damals
denn bei cum-ex und den ähnlichen
cum-geschäften handelt es sich um den
größten Finanzskandal in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik bei cum-ex geht man
davon aus dass mindestens 12 Milliarden
Euro Steuerschaden entstanden ist
hierbei haben sich sehr wohlhabende
Menschen zusammen
finanzmarktakteur:innen die sich
offensichtlich für nichts zu schade
waren Steuergelder zurück erstatten
lassen die nie gezahlt wurden man muss
keine heilige sein um direkt zu merken
dass sowas vielleicht nicht ganz in
Ordnung ist und es ist mittlerweile klar
ja das war illegal und zwar von Anfang
an es wurden nicht nur Steuern
hinterzogen sondern öffentliche Gelder
in Milliardenhöhe zu Unrecht ausgezahlt
und der Staat somit beraubt Geld das an
anderen Stellen fehlt und trotz allem
versteckte man sich später hinter dem
Mantel der Unwissenheit und Unschuld und
bezahlte sogar Beratungsfirmen und
öffentlich zugängliche Gutachten für
scheinjägalität herzustellen
die kommen ex-geschäfte sind nur die
Spitze des Eisbergs wenn man sich die
finanziellen Schäden durch die den
ähnlichen Geschäften ankommt dort geht
es wahrscheinlich sogar am 28 Milliarden
Euro
ich komme gleich noch zu dem Antrag aber
wir müssen das Einbetten in das Thema
auch Demokratie und Vertrauen diese
Ausmaße abgesehen vom Thema
Finanzkriminalität erodieren auch
Fairness und die soziale Marktwirtschaft
in unserem Land die Reichen das muss man
leider so deutlich sagen werden
beikommen Ex noch reicher indem sie mit
Steuerbetrug die Staatskasse ausnehmen
während normale Menschen sie mit ihren
Steuern auf Einkommen und Umsätze recht
schaffen befüllen wir haben eine sehr
starke Konzentration der Vermögen in
Deutschland das Vermögens der 1% der
Menschen besitzt mehr als 90% der
gesamten anderen Menschen in unserem
Land und in diesem ein Prozent sind
mutmaßlich genau jene Personen enthalten
die durch die Kriminellen kommen
ex-geschäfte noch reicher wurden und
zwar auf Kosten des Staates und damit
der gesamten Gesellschaft und damit ist
es auch ein strukturelles macht Problem
und ein Problem für die Demokratie
dass wir als Staat solche Geschäfte
unter allen Umständen untersuchen und
aufklären ist daher extrem wichtig auch
für den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
der Untersuchungsausschuss 2016 hier im
Bundestag hat dazu einen wichtigen
Beitrag geleistet und das war gut so nun
zu ihrem Antrag noch einmal liebe
unionsfraktionen sie wollen den Blick im
Bundestag nun zum zweiten Mal auf diese
kriminellen Geschäfte richten allerdings
mit dem engen Fokus nur auf die
Finanzverwaltung in Hamburg und die
Geschäfte der Warburg Bank die ebenfalls
in Hamburg ansässig ist als Abgeordneter
aus Hamburg liegt mir wirklich viel
daran dass mögliche kriminelle
Machenschaften lückenlos aufgeklärt
werden aber in der Hamburgischen
Bürgerschaft läuft bereits seit 2020 ein
parlamentarischer Untersuchungsausschuss
der genau dieses Thema in den Blick
nimmt der einsetzungsantrag von damals
enthält fast deckungsgleich die
Fragestellung die Sie jetzt hier im
Bundestag erneut aufwerfen möchten im
Untersuchungsausschuss in Hamburg wurden
die für die relevanten Akten auch von
der Staatsanwaltschaft Köln
durchgearbeitet und alle an der
Entscheidung beteiligten Personen
befragt fast alle sogar zweimal und auch
die Mitglieder des Finanzausschusses der
letzten Wahlperiode werden sich ein
Besucher im Untersuchungsausschuss in
Hamburg in den letzten Wochen gut
erinnern die umfassenden Untersuchungen
in Hamburg sind auf der zielgrabe die
relevante Frage ist welchen
Erkenntnisgewinn durch den von Ihnen
vorgeschlagenen inhaltlichen Fokus auf
die Hamburger Vorfälle ein
Untersuchungsausschuss hier im Bundestag
darüber hinaus leisten soll frau
Kollegin möchten Sie eine zwischen
deine Zwischenfrage von Herrn
selbstverständlich zu meinem geschätzten
Kollegen aus dem Finanzausschuss also
unter diesen Umständen das wird jetzt
bestimmt sehr freundlich ich versuche
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Frau
Kollegin Beck vielen Dank dass Sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen sie haben ja
gerade den ehemaligen Kollegen Gerd
schick sehr intensiv gelobt auch für
seine Verdienste im Finanzausschuss in
der Finanzpolitik und er ist ja jetzt
auch immer noch im Finanzbereich tätig
er arbeitet für finanzwende er ist dort
der Vorstand der Kopf von finanzwende
und dann würde ich mal schauen was Herr
schick genau zu diesem
Untersuchungsausschuss gesagt hat ich
zitiere ihn nämlich vom 04.04 gut dass
die Union jetzt mit einem
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag alle
Register für die commex Aufklärung zieht
Olaf Scholz Erinnerungslücken sind
unglaubhaft wir fordern endlich volle
Transparenz dann gibt's hier eine schöne
Social Media Kachel mit dem Gesicht
ihres Kollegen Herrn schick drauf da
steht drauf Zitat Scholz darf mit seiner
Verschleierungstaktik nicht durchkommen
und vor dem Hintergrund
vor dem Hintergrund ihrer Aussagen zu
Herrn schick würde mich doch ihre
Position dazu interessieren ob sie ein
schicker zustimmen würden oder ob sie
das für falsch halten
also Herr schick spricht für sich selbst
er hat finanzwende sogar mit gegründet
und natürlich bin ich und das führe ich
hier ja auch aus extrem doll für
Aufklärung und wenn wir uns hier im Bund
und wir haben ein paar mehr Kompetenzen
das hätte ich sogar jetzt gleich auch
noch gesagt als in Hamburg das stimmt ja
ja ich möchte gern die Chance ergreifen
wenn ein pur kommt und Sie haben ja nun
mal über ein Viertel der Abgeordneten
dass wir dann die relevanten
Fragestellungen die sonst noch offen
sind auch noch mit abdecken und das ist
die Argumentation die ich hier vorlege
ich finde allerdings auch dass es
manchmal einfacher ist von außerhalb der
als parlamentarische Repräsentantin dann
noch mal andere Worte zu wählen als wenn
man jetzt in der Rolle eines MdB ist und
diese Differenzierung ist glaube ich
auch manchmal noch wichtig
so ich hoffe die Frage ist beantwortet
das muss man dann immer noch Fragen
meine erste Zwischenfrage nach einem
Halbjahren aber vielen Dank
also die Frage ist nämlich welchen
Erkenntnisgewinn durch den von Ihnen
vorgeschlagenen inhaltlichen Fokus auf
die Hamburger Vorfälle ein
Untersuchungsausschuss hier im Bundestag
darüber hinaus leisten soll wir haben
das habe ich gerade gesagt ein paar
weitergehende Kompetenzen im Bund im
Vergleich mit den Ländern aber der
erwartete inhaltliche Mehrwert mit
dieser engen auf Hamburg beschränkten
Fragestellungen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
ist stark begründungswürdig ich finde es
spannend und wir als Grüne finden
spannend wenn man den ganzen krummen
Themenkomplex noch mal untersucht denn
es gibt in der Tat relevante Bereiche
wie zum Beispiel die kommunengeschäfte
die vom finanziellen Umfang deutlich
gravierender sind als cumex und ich
finde da das gar nicht vorkommt bei
ihnen ist die Frage erlaubt worum es
ihnen im Kern eigentlich geht um echte
zusätzliche Aufklärungsarbeit oder aber
vielleicht dann doch eher um
parteipolitische Motive herzlichen Dank
weckt die Sprecherin für Finanzen der
Bündnis Grünen im Raum steht ja die
Frage ob eine Intervention aus der
Politik beim Verzicht auf
Steuerrückzahlungen eine Rolle gespielt
hat mittendrin der damalige Hamburger
Hamburger Oberbürgermeister oder Scholz
der mittlerweile Bundeskanzler ist
Christian Göcke jetzt für die Linken
Sprecher für Finanzpolitik ob wir als
Linksfraktion wollen diesen
Untersuchungsausschuss es muss endlich
Rainer Tisch gemacht werden denn
Deutschland braucht weder ein Pinocchio
Kanzler bzw ein Kanzler der
bemerkenswerte Teil am Visier hat und
ich sage Ihnen auch ganz deutsche
deutlich wer als Linke kaufen dem
Kanzler auch seine Erinnerungslücken
nicht ab und laut Umfragen auch 70% der
Deutschen nicht ihr Kanzler meine Damen
und Herren von der SPD hat sich in
Widersprüche verstrickt und darüber Herr
Kollege Rudi kann auch ihre diffuse Rede
heute nicht hinweg täuschen statt sich
hier heute vor Panzer zu werfen
sollten Sie mal lieber dafür sorgen dass
ihre 45.000 Euro Parteispenden die die
SPD Hamburg bekommen hat von der Warburg
Bank zurückgezahlt werden dass wir heute
mal einen Beitrag gewesen und eine
Ankündigung meine Damen und Herren was
für merkenswert ist dass der Kanzler
behauptet ihr sei ja schon immer der
Meinung gewesen um Ex sei illegal
gewesen trotzdem traf er sich dreimal
dreimal mit dem warburg-chef olarius als
längst schon gegen ihn ermittelt wurde
das muss man sich mal vorstellen
zweimal sogar ohne Zeugen wie passt das
zusammen oder Scholz rief den olarius zu
Jahr direkt an also Scholz Griff zum
Hörer und bat ihn seine
Verteidigungsschrift an den
Finanzsenator zu schicken der dann mit
der grünen Minister Tinte die Argumente
unterstrich und dann an die
Steuerverwaltung warum dann kurz danach
die steuerrückforderung gegenüber der
Warburg Bank von 47 Millionen Euro die
kippt wurde
es muss lückenlos aufgeklärt und das
nächste Highlight meine Damen und Herren
wo sich der Kanzler noch im Juni im Juni
2020 Finanzausschuss noch an Details zu
einem Treffen erinnern konnte und erst
dann seine Erinnerung verlor als
Journalisten im September anhand der
olariustage Bücher weitere Treffen
enthüllen insofern hatte die grüne
finanzpolitiken Lisa Pauls Recht die
Scholz wegen dieser Erinnerungslücken
eben auch der Lüge bezichtigt hat und
ich teile diesen Verdacht meine Damen
und Herren
komisch
[Applaus]
aber drin jetzt vor dem
Untersuchungsausschuss letzte Woche
plötzlich ihre konkreten Erinnerungen
verloren hat und ich frage mich wirklich
ich frage mich wirklich eine ernstes ist
diese Scholz Amnesie hier in diesem
Kabinett irgendwie wieder anstecken
deshalb meine Damen und Herren liebe
grüne und liebe FDP ich erwarte von
Ihnen dass Sie sich jetzt nicht zu neuen
Bodyguards das kann das mutieren sondern
dass sie sich am Rheine machen hier
beteiligen ihr Arbeitgeber ist der
Wähler und der Arbeitgeber ist nicht das
Bundeskanzleramt bei der Damen und
Herren
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Union weiß ich ja auch eben noch
geklatscht haben vielleicht jetzt auch
ehrlicherweise muss auch der
Untersuchungsauftrag ausgeweitet werden
denn ihre Weste ist nämlich alles andere
als weiß abgesehen von dem Parteispenden
und sie haben dann viel höheren Betrag
von erwartenbank bekommen steht das
Agieren ihres ehemaligen Finanzministers
Schäuble genau so im Fokus denn warum
schickte dieser 2016 ein Schreiben an
die landesfinanzminister auch an mich
dass die Untersuchung der
ex-geschäfte massiv behindert hat viele
offene Fragen meine Damen und Herren
Rainer Tisch ist jetzt das Motto wir als
Linksfraktion werden alles
parlamentarische Mögliche tun vielen
Dank
christian war ehemaliger Finanzminister
in Brandenburg jetzt Sprecher für
Finanzpolitik der linken und er hat sich
über eine Tatsache beklagt die in der
Tat immer wieder zu beklagen sind
Untersuchungsausschüssen dass die
dortigen Zeugen sehr häufig unter
Amnesie Leiden das ist nichts neues das
hatte schon immer gegeben und es ist
nicht gut Markus jemand jetzt für die
FDP der Finanzkrise sprechen
die CDU jetzt endgültig auch in der
Opposition angekommen
gut anderthalb Jahre nach der Arbeit
kann man das ja auch erwarten auch wenn
der Rollenwechsel dem ein oder anderen
schon auch noch nicht leicht fällt
deshalb bin ich auch tatsächlich geneigt
dass jetzt in Rede stehende Druckwerk
als das zu verstehen was es ganz
offensichtlich auch ist nämlich der
Versuch wirksame Oppositionsarbeit die
Skandalisierung lange bekannter und vor
allem auch schon mehrfach debattierter
Sachverhalte soll vor allem
medienwirksam ausgeschlachtet werden und
und nicht missverstanden zu werden es
ist gut dass es diese parlamentarischen
Minderheitenrechte gibt denn oft genug
müssen Dinge tatsächlich mit
weitgehenderen Möglichkeiten untersucht
werden als dies im parlamentarischen
Alltag möglich ist insofern ist es
selbstverständlich ihr gutes Recht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union einen
solchen Ausschuss zu fordern und
selbstverständlich werden wir auch der
Überweisung in den zuständigen Ausschuss
zustimmen es ist allerdings auch unser
gutes Recht
diesen Antrag als das zu bezeichnen was
er aus unserer Sicht ist nämlich Theater
und das auch noch im falschen
Schauspielhaus
inhaltlich fällt es nämlich auch bei
aufmerksamer Betrachtung äußerst schwer
eine deutlich veränderte Situation
gegenüber dem bekannten Sachstand der
letzten Jahre zu erkennen
nach jahrelangen Recherchen von vielen
doch in Teilen ausgesprochen
hochmotivierten Journalisten
hochqualifizierten Journalisten und zum
Teil auch hochmotivierten ehemaligen
Kollegen sind die Erkenntnisse doch
weitgehend überschaubar mehr noch es
gibt sie eben nicht die bahnbrechende
Entwicklung die CDU und CSU hier gerade
herbei argumentieren wollen oder um es
anders auszudrücken wirklich alle in der
Sache Beteiligten wurden in den
vergangenen Jahren und zum Teil mehrfach
auf alle möglichen Zusammenhänge und
Hintergründe befragt auch vermag ich
nicht zu glauben dass ich
Erinnerungslücken durch einen erneuten
Untersuchungsausschuss schließen lassen
das kann man gut finden das kann man
schlecht finden aber man sollte nicht
einfach darüber hinwegsehen deshalb
sieht die FDP schon aufgrund fehlender
neuer Erkenntnisse derzeit keine
Notwendigkeit eine Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschuss im deutschen
Bundestag es ist viel mehr meines
Erachtens doch auch so liebe Kollegen
der Union weil ihm die Ergebnisse der
bisherigen Befragungen im
Finanzausschuss im parlamentarischen
Untersuchungsausschuss der Hansestadt
Hamburg nicht gefallen
instrumentalisieren Sie dieses
parlamentarische Gremium nun dazu
Schlagzeilen zu produzieren
im übrigen
gilt dass die von der Union im Antrag
angesprochenen Themen ihrem Wesenskern
nach weitgehend einfach nach Hamburg
verortet gehören und genau deshalb gibt
es doch auch diesen Ausschuss schon es
ist doch wirklich schleierhaft inwiefern
ein Untersuchungsausschuss des
Bundestages Erkenntnisse zu möglichen
Vorgängen im Hamburger
oberbürgermeisterbüro oder der
Hamburgischen Finanzverwaltung sammeln
soll der Zusammenhang mit der
Bundespolitik ist nur in wenigen Teil
Aspekten gegeben die isoliert betrachtet
die Begründung für die Einsetzung des
Ausschusses auf Bundesebene sehr dünn
werden lassen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Union das ist alles
eigentlich auch gar nicht von der Hand
zu weisen und ich hoffe doch eigentlich
auch sehr dass wir eigentlich darin sind
keine Parallelen aufklärungsstrukturen
aufbauen zu wollen Aufklärung ja
was wir aber nicht benötigen sind zwei
Ausschüsse in der gleichen Sache lassen
Sie doch die Hamburger Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ihre Arbeit machen und
Untersuchungsausschuss dort arbeiten ich
glaube wir wissen ganz genau was zu tun
ist und brauchen keine Unterstützung von
der Seitenlinie
vermutlich ist es der derzeitige
Lebenstraum mancher in der cdu/csu der
Ampelkoalition und Bundeskanzler Scholz
das Leben schwer zu machen das allein
aber sollte nicht der Anspruch an ihre
eigene Arbeit sein auch Sie sollten
Interesse daran haben ihre Ressourcen
gewinnbringende einzusetzen und die
künstliche Beatmung eines Themas das
einfach durch ist zu beenden herzlichen
Dank
verständlich die Fraktionen der Ampel
versuchen dieses Thema herunterzureden
die
Oppositionen Bausch des auf will ja
diesen Untersuchungsausschuss und
beantragt ihn hiermit auch Matthias
heuer von der cdu/csu wird das auch tun
erst mit dem Finanzausschuss
möchte gerne einen Schlussstrich ziehen
ein Schlussstrich unter die Aufklärung
der Steueraffäre stolz Warburg aber es
ist die Aufgabe des Parlaments
Regierungshandeln zu kontrollieren genau
hinzuschauen vor allem dann wenn so
viele offene Fragen und Widersprüche wie
in diesem Fall bestehen die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger haben einen Anspruch darauf
zu erfahren warum sich der Mann der
heute Bundeskanzler ist mehrfach
stundenlang mit einem Bänker getroffen
hat gegen den mittlerweile sogar Anklage
erhoben wurde
wegen 14 Fällen der besonders schweren
Steuerhinterziehung wegen einem
Steuerschaden von knapp 280 Millionen
Euro und als Olaf Scholz ihn dreimal
traf und ihm dann auch noch hinterher
telefonierte dann wusste Olaf Scholz
dass gegen ihn wegen schwerer
Steuerhinterziehung ermittelt wird man
darf und ich würde sagen man muss von
einem Regierungschef wie Olaf Scholz
erwarten können dass er sich mit aller
Kraft solchen kriminellen Machenschaften
entgegenstellt dass er kriminelle keine
Handlungsanweisungen gibt sondern dass
er ihnen klipp und klar sagt dass sie
mit einem steuerraub nicht davonkommen
und man darf auch erwarten dass Herr
Scholz den steuerräubern sinnbildlich
nicht auch noch dem Weg zum Fluchtwagen
zeigt und wir als CDU und CSU haben ja
versucht
parlamentarisch alle Register zu ziehen
wir haben mehrfach versucht den
Bundeskanzler vor dem Finanzausschuss
des Deutschen Bundestages dazu zu
befragen das hat die Ampelkoalition
mehrfach verhindert mit ihrer Mehrheit
gegen die gesamte Opposition
wir haben eine Aktuelle Stunde beantragt
und Olaf Scholz hat geschwiegen
also ich will Ihnen mal was sagen wenn
Sie die Sitzung auf aus Anfang 2020
ansprechen da gab es einen Kanzler auf
der Flucht der nach 45 Minuten wieder
weg musste der ist später gekommen er
ist früher gegangen es gab zwei Minuten
jede Fraktion hatte eine eine
Wortmeldung und da hat er sich sogar
noch erinnert an das woran er sich heute
nicht mehr erinnert das nur Zwischenruf
so und in regierungsbefragung hat er
sich entzogen auf schriftliche Fragen
entzieht sich der Bundeskanzler
berechtigten Fragen von Journalistin und
Journalisten stellt er sich nicht die
müssen sogar einklagen dass Herr Scholz
mit ihnen über cumex und seine Werbung
Verstrickungen spricht und weil die
ampelfraktion weil Herr Scholz der
mauert ist ein Untersuchungsausschuss
hier zur Sachverhalt auf dem zwingend
erforderlich und auch Grüne und FDP
wollten da ja mal aufklären
und warum hat Herr schrodi und die SPD
warum haben die eigentlich so viel Angst
vor der Aufklärung hören wir doch mal
rein was Grüne und FDP damals gesagt
haben zu dem Zeitpunkt als der schrodi
meinte Herr Scholz hat schon vollständig
alles aufgeklärt da haben die Grünen
behauptet Olaf Scholz aber den Bundestag
belogen er habe etwas zu verbergen die
FDP hat danach behauptet herr Scholz sie
jetzt Zweifel an seiner Integrität und
Glaubwürdigkeit politische Einflussnahme
sei die einzig plausible Erklärung das
sagen ihre Kollegen so doch mit der
Regierungsübernahme von FDP und Grünen
haben sie ihren Aufklärungsfilm
plötzlich verloren den haben sie nämlich
an der Pforte ihrer Ministerien wohl
abgegeben und ich appelliere an Sie
auch aus auch aus ihren Reihen haben
hochgeschätzte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sehr viel Aufklärungsarbeit geleistet
behalten Sie bitte dieses
aufklärungsinteresse
Opfern Sie es bitte nicht einen blinden
koalitions Gehorsam gegenüber der SPD es
geht hier um die Durchsetzung von
Bundesrecht es geht um Milliarden
Schaden für den steuerhaushalt auf
Bundesebene es geht um das Agieren und
die Glaubwürdigkeit des Bundeskanzlers
wir haben im Bund deutlich umfassendere
Möglichkeiten zur Aufklärung als die
Hamburgische Bürgerschaft und dem wird
sich auch der Bundeskanzler nicht
entziehen können wir werden alles daran
setzen die vollständige Aufklärung der
Steueraffäre stolz Werbung zu betreiben
alle Fraktionen dazu ein sich an dieser
Aufklärung zu beteiligen vielen Dank
Matthias Hauer war das für die cdu/csu
ganz anderer Meinung der Frage wird
jetzt Franka Heiligenstadt sein warum
sie ist Mitglied der SPD-Fraktion und
Mitglied im Finanzausschuss für die
Sozialdemokraten
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren wir alle
wissen
Untersuchungsausschüsse sind das
schärfste Schwert der Opposition das
Grundgesetz ermöglicht den Parlament die
Einrichtung von Untersuchungsausschüssen
damit sind diese Instrumente
parlamentarischer Kontrolle in einem
sehr hohen Rang abgesichert gerade weil
diese Instrumente aber so hart und auch
wichtig sind ist es auch Aufgabe von
Fraktionen und Abgeordneten sehr sorgsam
mit der Auswahl der Mittel und der
Entscheidung für einen
Untersuchungsausschuss umzugehen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ich nenne da mal ein Beispiel das zum
Beispiel die AFD inflationär
Untersuchungsausschüsse beantragt erst
gestern wieder zum
corona-fragen geschenkt da sind wir von
dieser Fraktion Rechtsaußen nicht anders
gewohnt aber sehr geehrter Herr merte
erstmal nun mal nicht mehr da aber ich
hätte ihn gerne die Frage gestellt von
Ihnen und Ihrer Fraktion hätte ich doch
etwas deutlich mehr erwartet sieht so
die von ihnen angekündigte konstruktive
Oppositionsarbeit aus
sieht die Arbeit so aus wenn ich das
anschaue angesichts der Punkte die schon
längst durchgearbeitet sind was ist
nicht schon alles geschehen meine
Kollegen haben das ausgeführt um die
kommen ex-geschäfte der warburg-brand
aufzuklären in einer Kürze wir haben
zwei Presse Veröffentlichungen aus den
Tagebüchern das kommt expandisolarius
wir haben drei Befragungen im Bundestag
im Ausschuss eine zunächst verhinderte
Razzia da Kölner Staats Landwirtschaft
in Hamburg und ein zweieinhalb Jahre
dauernden Untersuchungsausschuss der
Hamburger Bürgerschaft zu den Fragen der
cum-ex-geschäfte der warburgbank
Ergebnisse aller Untersuchungen bis
jetzt sehr geehrter Herr Mittelberg der
Abschlussbericht wird natürlich noch
erstellt werden da war nichts da ist
nichts und da wird auch nie etwas sein
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
zumindest nicht in Bezug auf ihren
untersuchungsantrag es gab keine
Einflussnahme auf die Entscheidung der
Finanzverwaltung es gibt keinen Schaden
in Bezug auf staatliche Steuereinnahmen
weil alle Steuerschulden zurückgezahlt
wurden und Zinsen dafür ebenfalls
festgesetzt wurden und es gibt auch
keine Widersprüche in den Aussagen von
Olaf Scholz das können sie so oft
behaupten wie sie soll wollen wenn man
was falsch behauptet und immer wieder
wird es dadurch nicht richtiger
und selbst meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren die kritische Öffentlichkeit
in den Medien und ich gebe mal
ausnahmsweise in meinen Worten
zusammengefasst einen Artikel der
bild-Zeitung vom 14 April 2023 wieder
dort heißt es sinngemäß selbst der
größte Kritiker gemeint ist der
ehemalige Kollege die Masi konnte keine
entscheidenden Widersprüche zwischen den
Scholz Auftritten nennen stattdessen
jede Menge Spekulation und die Bild
weiter Fazit endloses polit-theater
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
meine
Heizung ist es geht hier der
cdu/csu-fraktion wirklich nicht um einen
Erkenntnis gewinnt sondern es geht ihnen
nur darum weiter mit Dreck zu schmeißen
damit nur ja irgendetwas hängen bleibt
sie wollen die Fortsetzung des
politheaters meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren sie wollen mit möglichst
unwahren Unterstellungen und nicht
belegten Behauptungen arbeiten haben sie
ja jetzt auch schon gerade wieder
gemacht weil niemand in ihren Reihen das
Format des Bundeskanzlers Olaf Scholz
besetzt denn
Olaf Scholz ist ein Bundeskanzler der
uns in schwierigen Zeiten besonnen klug
und weitsichtig durch wirklich schwere
Herausforderungen führt und das ist auch
gut so meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
ohne
zu haben bei ihrer Aufregung touché
denke ich
Untersuchungsausschüsse sind Rechte der
jeweiligen Parlamente auf ihrer Ebene
also nochmal zum Erklären ein
parlamentarischer Untersuchungsausschuss
in einem Landtag befasst sich mit
Landesaufgaben ein parlamentarischer
Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag mit
bundesfragen meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der CDU CSU es
gibt hier keine zusätzliche Instanz bei
der man in Revision oder Berufung gehen
kann wenn einem die Ergebnisse der
vorherigen Ebene nicht passen aus diesem
Grund ist es auch fraglich ob die von
Ihnen im Antrag benannten Fragenkomplexe
überhaupt
verfassungskonform sind der Sachverhalt
um die cum-ex-geschäfte der Warburg Bank
ist nun tatsächlich vorwärts und
rückwärts in allen unterschiedlichen
Facetten durchleuchtet worden sie
scheinen das tote fährt noch in
irgendein Ziel Reiten zu wollen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren und sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der CDU
CSU-Fraktion sie führen ja an neue
Erkenntnisse auf Bundesebene gewinnen zu
wollen ich fände Erkenntnis bringender
wäre es vielleicht wenn sie zu anderen
Themen Untersuchungsaufträge vielleicht
sogar in ihrer eigenen Fraktion
bearbeiten würden wir würden auf Anhieb
ein paar Beispiele einfallen was ist mit
den maskendeals der Abgeordneten der
letzten Legislaturperiode wir sind die
wir sind die Vorgänge der
aserbaidschan-affäre aufgearbeitet
worden wie ist es eigentlich mit den
Ergebnissen der lobbyismus-affäre um den
Kollegen philipp am Tor und den
ehemaligen Wirtschaftsminister Peter
Altmaier und dem ehemaligen
Verteidigungsminister zu Gutenberg
umgegangen worden aber wenn es darum
geht dass die CDU CSU in ihrem eigenen
Laden mal eine Aufarbeitung startet wird
sie seltsam still seltsam still jedoch
vor dem Bundestagswahlen wie zuletzt mit
der Razzia in Köln in Bezug auf die
Fragestellung der fiju ist in jedes
Mittel recht
aber bei der Union Tradition denn erst
vor kurzem mussten wir zur Kenntnis
nehmen das bereits unter Adenauer mit
der bnd-affäre staatliche Institutionen
Hilfe auf dem politischen Mitbewerber
zum Schluss kommen
Behörden und parlamentarische Kulturen
geben ja ich komme zum Schluss frau
Präsidentin für parteipolitische Zwecke
zu nutzen Frau Kollegin schaden damit
der Demokratie
Frauke Heiligenstadt war das für die SPD
der Bundestag diskutiert hier über den
Untersuchungsausschuss
für die afd-fraktion hat kein
gottschalkersburg
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin vor
allen Dingen sehr geehrte Steuerzahler
es geht um Ihr Geld und auch liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und Wähler es
geht um Glaubwürdigkeit und das haben
sie eben verhandlungsfeld ganz und gar
verwirrt der Skandal um cumex da hat der
Bundeskanzler totale Transparenz
zugesagt sein Code ist aber eins drei
Null im ersten Gespräch was Kollege
Hauer im Finanzausschuss zitierte hatte
er sich ein ein Gespräch erinnert dann
waren es mindestens drei er hat sich die
Tagebucheinträge auf meine Frage hin zu
eigen gemacht da wusste er schon den
Teilen was dort drin statt meine Damen
und Herren und null heißt etwas später
weil dann auch noch Wirecard da hat ihr
Kanzler auch keine gute und der damalige
Finanzminister Figur gemacht dann auch
Aufgaben und tatsächlich die
Kanzlerkandidatur gefährdete jetzt hat
er null Erinnerung jeder normale Bürger
würde in burgerhaft für so eine
Erinnerungslücke das ist komplett
unglaubwürdig meine Damen und Herren
und mittlerweile schreibt dieser Krimi
ja schon Bücher es gibt darüber
entsprechend Dokumentationen und warum
wir hier auch die Aufklärung wollen das
ist ein Grundproblem unserer Demokratie
mittlerweile denn die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft in Hamburg und
ich betone wollte nichts feststellen
Bonn musste ja auch hier an anderen
Stellen entsprechend hilfsweise
eintreten meine Damen und Herren und
klar ist für mich wenn die Justiz nicht
handeln will in Hamburg und ist weiter
offene Fragen gibt das haben die
Kollegen hier betont für Fehlverhalten
Erinnerungslücken die nicht glaube ich
sind dann muss eben die Politikern und
zwar mit dem schärfsten Schwert und das
heißt sie an dieser Stelle
Untersuchungsausschuss
und Frau Beck sie sitzen mit in Hamburg
in der Regierung auch da hätte ich mir
entsprechend in der Bürgerschaft viel
mehr aufklärungswählen gewünscht aus
diesem Grund begrüßen wir als
afd-fraktion die Einsetzung eines
zweiten Untersuchungsausschuss aber wenn
man mal über Demokratie und
Glaubwürdigkeit sprechen liebe Kollegen
der Union wir hätten uns gestern auch
gewünscht dass sie den Corona
Untersuchungsausschuss unterstützt
hätten denn da ist auch etwas faul im
starte Dänemark und was ist eigentlich
mit North Stream dass wir fordern da ist
auf deutsche Infrastruktur ein Anschlag
verübt worden und sie rühren keine Hand
demokratisch wäre gewesen was sie hier
hochhalten uns auch dort zu unterstützen
wie wir es natürlich als demokratische
Fraktionen auch tun werden mit diesem
Untersuchungsausschuss
ja und ich denke schon dass wir uns von
dem Verhalten was ich hier heute auch in
Teilen von der cdu/csu hören konnten
abgrenzen wollen denn wir wollen
tatsächlich wieder Kollege Görke sagte
Licht ins Dunkel bringen es ist nicht
unsere Absicht den Bundeskanzler und
tragbar zu machen wenn er dann aufgrund
unserer Tatsachen die wir ermitteln das
so wäre dann ist es gut so aber dieser
zweite Untersuchungsausschuss soll in
erster Linie die Wahrheit ans Licht
bringen Ihnen liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürger das Vertrauen in Demokratie und
eine funktionierende Justiz z.B in
Hamburg zurückgehen und wir tun gut
daran wenn wir das verinnerlichen und
nicht Hauptaugenmerk darauf liegen und
da sage ich dann auch Gott bewahre dass
die cdu/csu sicherlich die nächsten
Kanzler in Form von Herrn März stellen
wollen das ist nicht unser Ziel
Aufklärung Transparenz und glaubwürdige
Demokratie das ist unser Ziel und das
werden unterstützen
[Applaus]
ist für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und Bruno sitzt im
Finanzausschuss für seine Fraktion
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch ich möchte
zu Beginn noch einmal unmissverständlich
klarstellen dass es natürlich
zuallererst einmal das parlamentarische
Rechte Union ist ein
Untersuchungsausschuss zu beantragen da
gibt es überhaupt keinen Zweifel und
selbst redend Herr Hauer teilen wir auch
als grüne Bundestagsfraktion das
grundsätzliche Anliegen cumex lückenlos
aufzuklären Frau Beck hat darauf
hingewiesen das zeigt sich schon dadurch
dass wir 2016 auf den ersten
Untersuchungsausschuss zu cumex gedrängt
haben und gleichzeitig muss man
allerdings festhalten dass wesentliche
Fragen zum Versagen von
Kontrollinstanzen von politischer
Untätigkeit aber auch zum Einfluss der
Banken Lobbys auf die Gesetzgebung offen
geblieben sind im ersten
Untersuchungsausschuss und das ist in
Teilen bis heute so deswegen finde ich
es auch grundsätzlich richtig und
geboten dass wir uns mit diesem
brisanten Thema auch weiterhin
auseinandersetzen auch wenn das hier im
Plenum sicherlich alle wissen möchte ich
gerade für die BürgerInnen die sich für
dieses ja nicht ganz leichte Thema
interessieren noch einmal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen worüber wir hier
eigentlich sprechen illegale
cum-ex-geschäfte das sind
Aktientransaktionen die kurz vor oder
nach dem Tag der Dividendenausschüttung
getätigt werden was die betrüger:innen
gemacht haben war die Aktien hin und her
zu schieben bis es dem Finanzamt nicht
mehr klar ist wer als Inhaber der
Wertpapiere eigentlich Anspruch auf die
Rückerstattung der Kapitalertragssteuer
hat in der Folge haben die
Finanzbehörden dann die
Kapitalertragssteuer auf Dividenden
mehrfach zurückerstattet die der Staat
allerdings nur einmalig eingenommen hat
allein in Deutschland geht es da um ein
Schaden von mindestens 10 Milliarden
Euro diese milliarden wurden dem Fiskus
und damit natürlich auch den
SteuerzahlerInnen durch die finanztricks
verschiedener Akteure rechtswidrig
geraubt und so klar muss man das auch
hier benennen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
allen Bürgerinnen die in Deutschland
arbeiten und ihre Steuern zahlen ist
klar dass etwas nicht stimmen kann wenn
man vom Finanzamt Steuern
zurückerstattet bekommt die man
eigentlich nie gezahlt hat und wir
brauchten niemand erzählen dass auch nur
ein Akteur einer der beteiligten Akteure
das nicht wusste sie haben bewusst und
zielgerichtet das Finanzamt betrogen und
so Milliarden auf dem Rücken der
Allgemeinheit ein Geheimnis und ja
gerade deswegen wegen des
volkswirtschaftlichen Schadens für die
Allgemeinheit geht es ja auch um eine
Frage der Gerechtigkeit von daher ist
sachbezogene Aufklärung und vor allem
auch die Schließung weiterer bestehender
gesetzlicher Lücken im Bereich der
Finanzkriminalität unsere Pflicht
gegenüber den Steuerzahlerinnen und
gerade auch im Sinne der Gerechtigkeit
allerdings liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union hat ihr Antrag
leider wenig zu tun mit konstruktiver
und Sache orientierter Aufklärung um
maßgeblich stehen sie nämlich und das
wurde ja mehrfach angesprochen genau die
gleichen Fragen die auch im Hamburger
Untersuchungsausschuss bereits behandelt
worden gleichzeitig vergessen Sie
beispielsweise das gesamte Thema kumkum
obwohl es auch hier sehr berechtigten
Anlass zur Aufklärung gäbe bei einem
volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden von
schätzungsweise 30 Milliarden Euro der
damit dreimal so hoch ist wie bei cumex
und ich sag's Ihnen auch überraschend
ist diese Lücke in ihrem Antrag nicht
denn sie haben bereits ihre
Regierungszeit dieses Thema konsequent
ignoriert sie haben keinerlei Ambitionen
gezeigt derartige Steuergestaltung durch
scharfe Gesetze zu unterbinden der
Finanzminister war Wolfgang Schäuble von
der CDU das gehört zur Wahrheit auch
dazu liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
da muss ich Ihnen ganz ganz ganz klar
sagen ein Untersuchungsausschuss ein
Untersuchungsausschuss zum Sammelbecken
von Schuldzuweisungen und Vermutungen zu
instrumentalisieren führt jeden
berechtigten aufklärungsgedanken
absurdum und wird dem Schaden dieser
illegalen Steuergestaltungen eben gerade
nicht gerecht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union so und jetzt
jetzt noch einmal Blick nach vorne denn
es gibt noch immer gesetzliche Lücken
die wir dringend schließen müssen ich
denke dabei beispielsweise an die
Unterbindung von missbräuchlichen
Dividenden abitrage Geschäften das ist
ein ganz konkreter Punkt aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag der muss ins
steuerfernes Gesetz jetzt rein wir
beraten es weil damit wir endlich vor
die Welle kommen genau das erreichen was
uns bei cum und cumex nicht gelungen ist
hier steht der Finanzminister jetzt in
der Pflicht ganz konkrete Vorschläge für
das Steuer fernes Gesetz zur
unterbreiten
und abschließend liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen möchte ich noch einmal betonen
wir Grüne wollen sachgerechte aufklären
wir beteiligen uns aber nicht an einer
parteipolitischen wahlkampfschlacht
zwischen ihnen von der Union und den
Kolleginnen von der SPD das machen wir
nicht wir werden weiterhin dafür kämpfen
die Finanzkriminalität in Deutschland
einzudämmen im Sinne unseres gemeinsam
Anliegens einer transparenten und
gerechten Steuerpolitik ohne
Schlupflöcher für Großbanken und für
Großkonzerne und ja dazu braucht es auch
weitere Aufklärung und an der werden wir
uns als grüne Bundestagsfraktion
intensiv und konstruktiv beteiligen wie
bei Hauer herzlichen Dank
soweit die Ankündigung aus der grünen
Fraktion und die Unionsfraktion hat er
diesen Untersuchungs diesen
Untersuchungsausschuss beantragt für die
Unionsfraktion spricht nun Patrick
Schmida sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen ja wir
fordern die Einsetzung eines
parlamentarischen
Untersuchungsausschusses zum Komplex
Scholz Warburg Bank ja wir wollen das
schärfste Schwert einsetzen dass die
Opposition einsetzen kann und wenn es
das Erfordernis noch gebraucht hätte
dann ist es die Beiträge vor allem der
SPD und der Opposition und der
Koalitionsfraktionen die das heute klar
gemacht haben man fragt sich doch an die
Genossen gerichtet haben Sie etwas zu
verbergen und Wasser haben sie zu
verbergen dass sie sich so dagegen
wehren dass diese Dinge aufgeklärt
werden und ich sage Ihnen warum muss es
diesen Untersuchungsausschuss geben
weil wir die Wahrheit wissen wollen weil
ganz Deutschland wissen muss woran es
mit diesem Bundeskanzler ist
ein Bundeskanzler der
Scheunentor große Gedächtnislücken hat
ein Bundeskanzler der bei keiner
Gelegenheit zu einem Gesprächspartnern
zu spüren lässt er habe mehr Durchblick
ein besseres Gedächtnis als jeder andere
in diesem Raum dieser Bundeskanzler kann
sich an Gespräche mit einem bedeutenden
Hamburger Bürger über zweistellige
Millionen Summen nur schwach oder gar
nicht mehr erinnern wie glaubwürdig ist
denn diese Person
[Applaus]
Indizien das Herr Scholz vorsichtig
ausgedrückt flexibel mit der Wahrheit
umgeht
am 1 Juli 2020 ist gesagt worden im
Finanzausschuss kann er sich an Themen
eines Gesprächs mit Herrn olearius
erinnern
als bekannt für das hat drei Gespräche
gegeben mindestens drei Gespräche kann
er sich an nichts mehr erinnern und ich
habe schon den Eindruck dieser
Erinnerungslücken dieser
Gedächtnisschwund grassiert in der
gesamten Koalition wenn ich mir das
Verhalten einiger grüner anschaue die
sich vorher in Opposition noch ganz
anders geäußert haben der einzige der
dort Rückgrat hat ist Herr Dr schick
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
das alles muss aufgeklärt werden was ist
dem Fall Scholz Warburg Geschehen bzw
unterlassen worden haben wir einen
Bundeskanzler der extreme
Erinnerungslücken hat haben wir einen
Bundeskanzler der flexibel mit der
Wahrheit umgeht beides wäre
unverantwortlich und würde in die Frage
münden kann ich so jemandem unser Land
anvertrauen
und meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
will auf das noch eingehen was Herr
schrodi hier gesagt hat Herr schroti zum
ersten Mal haben sie gesagt die Union
würde behaupten seinen Schaden
entstanden darüber kann man ja
nachdenken das wird Schaden kommt in
unserem Antrag nicht einmal vor müssen
Sie vielleicht mal richtig lesen zweiter
Punkt sie stellen in Frage dass das
bundesstaatsprinzip hier gewahrt ist
nämlich dass wir verantwortlich als
Bundestag diese Sache aufklären könnten
ich sage Ihnen der Bundestag ist
zweifelsfrei zuständig für die
Kapitalertragssteuer um die es hier geht
er muss auch dessen Handhabung in einem
krassen Einzelfall für den Steuerfall
Warburg Bank beleuchten können es geht
um den Vollzug von Bundesrecht und fast
zur Hälfte um Steueransprüche des Bundes
und es ist zudem fraglich und offen
warum sich Hamburg in dieser Rechtsfrage
die bundesweit einheitlich zu
beantworten ist und die 15 Bundesländer
einheitlich beantwortet haben sich nicht
abgestimmt hat mit oder den anderen
Ländern der Bundesfinanzminister muss
der Hamburg durch Weisung zum
rechtsvollzug bringen und deshalb meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
[Musik]
eines Jahr bedeutet viel Arbeit und
bindet große Ressourcen diesen Aufwand
verantwortet aber nicht meine Fraktion
nicht der Antragsteller diesen Aufwand
verantwortet der Bundeskanzler sein
Ausweichen vor den Fragen der
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seine
Erinnerungslücken haben diesen Ausschuss
unvermeidbar gemacht und kein Parlament
das sich selbst und seine Aufgabe
wahrnimmt lässt sich so von einem
Regierungschef behandeln der
Bundeskanzler mit den drängenden Fragen
in steuerfrei am Ende bitte
kein Respekt vor dem Parlament für den
Parlament diesen Respekt haben sie
vermissen lassen der Bundeskanzler wir
wollen Aufklärung wir wollen die
Wahrheit wissen
viel Applaus aus der Unionsfraktion
übrigens die hier stark vertreten ist
hier beide Debatte zum
Untersuchungsausschuss den sie eben
einrichten möchte für die FDP nun
Maximilian Mauthausen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich habe sehr genau zugehört
was die Kollegen der Union hier
vorgetragen haben und auch für die
Freien Demokraten kann ich ganz deutlich
und eindeutig sagen selbstverständlich
haben auch wie ein aufklärungsinteresse
wenn irgendwo etwas schief läuft ich
muss aber auch auf der anderen Seite
sagen nichts von dem was sie entweder in
ihrem Antrag oder hier heute am
Rednerpult vorgetragen haben
rechtfertigt ein parlamentarischen
Untersuchungsausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages
ich bin zuversichtlich ich bin
zuversichtlich dass die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in Hamburg und dort ist das
Thema es wurde schon mehrfach
aufgeworfen dort ist die Zuständigkeit
er alles tun werden und ich hoffe auch
dass sie das Grundvertrauen in ihre
Leute in Hamburg haben dass sie für eine
entsprechende Aufklärung sorgen dann
bräuchten wir auch keine
Parallelstrukturen auch das gehört zum
sorgsam Umgang mit Steuergeld dazu und
dann muss ich auch
wenn ich genau aufnehme was hier gesagt
wurde muss ich mich doch über die ein
oder andere Aussage im Ton zutiefst
wundern denn auch der Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland bei allem was
aufgeklärt werden muss hat das Recht auf
die Unschuldsvermutung in Deutschland
und man kann nicht auf der einen Seite
in den Medien immer erzählen es kann
nicht sein dass Leute vorverurteilt
werden es kann nicht sein dass
Prominente mit Behauptung und Indizien
wie Sie es sagen vorverurteilt werden
und das gleiche dann hier vornehmen wenn
es für den eigenen politischen Vorteil
gereicht ich finde das ist nicht die
richtige Antwort und da muss man doch
genau hinhören was da ein oder andere
sagt Herr Mittelberg spricht von einer
Umkehr der Beweislast Herr Hauer hat
Angeklagte als Kriminelle bezeichnet
Herr Gottschalk von der AFD spricht von
beuge gehabt und herrscht niederwirft
mit Suggestivfragen um sich das ist doch
nicht der Umgang den ob wir in einem
parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss
wollen
wir nehmen eine Beobachtung politischer
Kulturen war und ich schaue da mal auf
die USA wo parlamentarische
Untersuchungsausschüsse oft als
öffentliches Tribunal verwendet werden
wo sie nicht mehr als Aufklärung dienen
sondern wo Leute öffentlichkeitswirksam
vorgeladen werden um eine eigene
politische Agenda durchzuziehen wo auch
in den Befragungen Suggestivfragen
vorgenommen werden und ich finde so
diese Kultur sollten wir in Deutschland
nicht Kultur werden lassen es geht um
einen Untersuchungsausschuss es geht
nicht um einen wahlkampfausschuss und
deswegen werden wir mit bestem Gewissen
an der Aufklärung teilhaben wir werden
aber keine Wahlkampfmanöver wir werden
aber keine Untersuchungsausschuss für
Wahlkampfmanöver missbrauchen und
deswegen können Sie auf unsere
konstruktive Mitarbeitern aber nicht
darauf dass wir die politische Kultur in
Deutschland in so eine Richtung drehen
werden vielen Dank
der fraktionslose Abgeordnete robertale
kommt
vielen Dank
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
erstens nicht nur private Banken sondern
auch die zum damaligen Zeitpunkt
öffentlich-rechtliche Landesbank die HSH
Nordbank haben in einem solchen Maßstab
die deutschen Steuerzahler betrogen dass
man nur von einer organisierten
Kriminalität sprechen kann
zweitens
Spitzenpolitiker haben bis hin zum
heutigen Bundeskanzler haben sogar aktiv
an der Vertuschung dieses Raubzuges auf
die öffentlichen Finanzen
mitgeholfen und versucht die
Rückforderung der erbeuteten
Steuermilliarden
einzuschränken oder zu verhindern
es muss
lückenlos aufgeklärt werden gerade
deshalb weil es sich hier um unseren
Bundeskanzler handelt und wir können
keinen Bundeskanzler tolerieren im Amt
bei dem man sich nicht sicher sein kann
dass er sich ein solch wichtigen Ding
immer erinnert und nicht nur wenn es ihm
passt und dass er im Zweifel bei einer
Entscheidung auch immer für die richtige
und die rechtlich saubere Sache Eintritt
deswegen muss das aufgeklärt werden und
deswegen unterstütze ich auch diese
Aufklärung ich sage aber auch drittens
sie klammern mit ihrem Antrag ihr
Antrags wirklich unzureichend bei der
CDU sie klammern die Geschäfte aus die
haben von der Bedeutung noch eine
wesentlich größere Bedeutung bis zu 30
Milliarden hat man der Presse lesen
können sind da hinterzogen worden
da fallen aber auch Namen wie zum
Beispiel Herr Schäuble oder Spahn der da
damalige Finanzminister Schäuble der hat
zwar veranlasst das hinterrückforderung
gemacht worden aber wieso hat es
überhaupt diese Löcher in unserem
Steuersystem gegeben wieso ist dieses
Geld zweckentfremdet worden von
Multimillionären gemacht wurden der
Kollege vielen Dank
und wer sie nur den Kanzler stürzen
wollen dann ist das für mich
besser werde
t besser
die Rede von robertaler mittlerweile
fraktionslos und für die SPD-Fraktion
spricht nun den Bacher
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir diskutieren
heute einen Antrag der Unionsfraktion
der symbolisch für die Politik dieser
Parteien steht es geht bei diesem Antrag
nicht um einen Erkenntnisgewinn für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger es geht auch
nicht darum hier einen Steuerskandal
aufzuarbeiten nein es geht rein um
politische Instrumentalisierung
parteipolitische Spielchen aber genau
dafür ist ein Untersuchungsausschuss als
schärfstes Schwert der Opposition eben
nicht da liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Untersuchungsausschüsse sind in
Deutschland seit der Weimarer Republik
ein fester Bestandteil der
parlamentarischen Demokratie und der
Auseinandersetzung zwischen Regierung
und Opposition und das ist auch gut so
der Mehrwert eines
Untersuchungsausschusses jetzt im
vorliegenden Fall ist aber nicht nur
schwer zu begründen er ist schlicht
nicht vorhanden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen man muss es so klar sagen es
geht um Behauptung die vor drei Jahren
ohne Belege in den Raum gestellt wurden
die längst widerlegt sind und jetzt
wieder aufgeräumt werden sollen um
politische Stimmung zu machen jeder der
sich ein wenig mit den Vorwürfen
beschäftigt hat der weiß da war nie was
dran es gab keine politische
Einflussnahme und bei allen
angestrengten Untersuchungen ist genau
nichts rausgekommen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wo soll hier der Mehrwert
für eine untersuchen weiterhin sein
sie zweifeln in ihrem Antrag an den
Aussagen und an der Glaubhaftigkeit
unseres Bundeskanzlers und wollen
hierfür einen Untersuchungsausschuss im
Bundestag einsetzen obwohl sie wissen
sowohl die Staatsanwaltschaft als auch
die Hamburger Bürgerschaft haben diese
Zweifel bereits längst ausführlich
widerlegt
die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Hamburg
hat zuletzt Anfang März diesen Jahres
dass sie dargelegt eindeutig dargelegt
dass sie im Zusammenhang mit dem
cum-ex-geschäften der Bank erst
überhaupt gar keinen Anfangsverdacht
gegen den Kanzler wegen uneinheitlicher
faulisch Aussage sehen würde ein Beweis
für eine Einflussnahme hat auch der
Hamburger Untersuchungsausschuss in über
zweieinhalb Jahren Tätigkeit eben nicht
erbracht glauben Sie etwa ihre
Parteifreunde in Hamburg haben in dem
Untersuchungsausschuss nicht ordentlich
gearbeitet
seit 2020 gibt es genau diesen
Untersuchungsausschuss dort wurden über
50 Zeuginnen und Zeugen angehört
insgesamt fanden bereits über 40
Sitzungen statt zu dem tagte der
cum-ex-untersuchungsausschuss in der 18
Legislaturperiode des Bundestages in 46
Sitzungen vernahm 70 Zeugin und Zeugen
und hörte eine Vielzahl von
Sachverständigen an jetzt einen neuen
Untersuchungsausschuss einzusetzen wäre
nicht nur völlig sinnlos sondern auch
unverhältnismäßig liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es mutet das muss man sagen es
mutet der Bayer bei einer schon so an
als wollen Sie hier auf Kosten der
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler
Bundesmittel dafür einsetzen einen
Sachverhalt zu untersuchen der bereits
in seiner Grenze durch unterschiedliche
Staatsorgane in unterschiedlichen Zeiten
untersucht wurde und zu ein und
demselben Ergebnis immer wieder gekommen
sind
es war nicht es gab nicht es ist nichts
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
neben keiner Aussicht auf neuen
Erkenntnisgewinn stellt sich ganz
grundlegend die Frage in wie weit der
Antrag der Unionsfraktion überhaupt
verfassungskonform ist wir scheint das
beinahe so dass sie Bundes- und Landes
Zuständigkeit mehrfach verwechseln das
ist klar in so einem wichtigen Verfahren
muss die Frage der
Verfassungskonformität klar überprüft
und festgestellt werden und das am
besten schnell durch den Ausschuss der
Wahlprüfung Immunität und
Geschäftsordnung heute wäre eine
Gelegenheit dazu ich komme zum Schluss
aber will auf einen bemerkenswertes
Zitat dass ich im Einverständnis mit der
Frau Präsidentin wiedergeben möchte ein
Bundestagsabgeordneter hat im Jahr 2001
in Bezug auf die Einsetzung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses für einen
zugegeben mittlerweile sehr vielen der
schwer geldaffären der CDU folgendes
gesagt
das ist ein eklatanter Missbrauch es ist
ein Untersuchungsausschuss tätig der ein
reines parteipolitisches Kampfinstrument
der Sozialdemokraten gegen die Union als
Ganzes geworden ist und der mit dem
untersuchungsschuss Auftrag etwas
festzustellen bis heute nichts zu tun
hat diese Worte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen habe ich mir von meinem
geschätzten Kollegen und heutigen
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Union geboren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich finde
wir sollten Friedrich März genau an
seinen eigenen Worten auch heute messen
sehr geehrter Herr Merz lassen Sie es
nicht zu dass ein Untersuchungsausschuss
in diesem Haus zu einem
parteipolitischen Kampfinstrument wird
und bewahren Sie sich selbst diesen Rest
an Glaubwürdigkeit herzlichen Dank
damit kommen wir zum letzten Redner in
dieser Debatte ob ein
Untersuchungsausschuss eingesetzt werden
soll und das ist Michael Frieser der
Justitia der Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin werde Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Scholz Warburg da geht ein
leichtes Beben vor allem durch die
SPD-Fraktion der die Sorge muss schon
sehr groß sein wenn man mit den
Standards und wir hätten gehofft es gäbe
heute etwas mehr zu sagen etwas mehr zu
bieten als wirklich die Stanzen die man
im Grunde als Regierung gegen jeden
Untersuchungsausschuss wir wissen wovon
wir reden ins Feld führen kann
Entschuldigung in diesem Fall reicht's
nicht ganz aus die grüne machen es
wesentlich geschickte wenn man zuhört
sie Weiten des Feld über die Frage
dessen was man noch alles untersuchen
müsste was in diesem Land alles
tatsächlich schief läuft trotz ihrer
Regierungsbeteiligung trotz der Kosten
die durch unzählige Staatssekretäre
erhöht und aufgebaut wurden aber egal
und deshalb müssen wir in den ab und zu
dann schon mal das Ergebnis auch ihre
Beteiligung an den bisherigen dann noch
mal unter die Nase halten Lisa Paus in
der Berliner Zeitung am 14 September
2020 es ist ganz klar Olaf Scholz hat
etwas zu verbergen und ums noch
deutlicher zu machen am 09.09.2020 ließe
sich dazu hinreisen im
redaktionsnetzwerk Olaf Scholz mit Ihrer
Erlaubnis Olaf Scholz hat den Bundestag
über seine Treffen mit der Warburg Bank
belogen Frau Pauls scheint mir etwas
weiter zu sein wer aber soweit nicht
gehen will
der muss ein erhöhtes Interesse daran
haben dass gerade ein solcher
Untersuchungsausschuss den Versuch
unternimmt einen erneuten Versuch
unternimmt das was an dieser Stelle im
Raum steht ein Elefant so groß wie die
versuchte Steuerhinterziehung da geht es
tatsächlich um die Frage ob man
47 Millionen Euro der Verjährung
überlässt und trotz Anweisungen des
Bundes weiterer 43 Millionen desselben
Schicksal eingliedern lassen will man
möchte uns glauben machen dass viele in
den Entscheidungsbereich einer
Finanzbeamtin der immer klammen haben
sie statt Hamburg und Frau Mast zu
zitieren geht's noch ist denn das
wirklich etwas was sie die
Öffentlichkeit glauben machen wollen es
ist mir unangenehm aber man muss immer
wieder mal darauf hinweisen
dieses nette Kerzen streuen um zu sagen
ein solcher Untersuchungsausschuss wäre
nicht nur obsolet sondern
gegebenenfalls tatsächlich
verfassungsrechtlich fragwürdig auch da
wieder ein Zitat ja geht's noch ein
Blick ins deutsche Grundgesetz 108 in
Verbindung mit 85 des Grundgesetzes die
Länder erheben die kapitalantragsteuer
im Auftrag des Bundes und sind
diesbezüglich sogar weisungsgebunden es
geht um steuereinheitlichkeit es geht um
das Geld aller deutschen Bürger und
nicht nur
eine sind not gerade den privatjes der
übrigens persönlich haften der
Gesellschaft da ist es ging nicht um die
Arbeitsplätze einer Bank es ging nicht
um Institutionen nein es geht um
millionenschwerde Privatleute die
gegebenenfalls an dieser Stelle etwas
leiden könnten und an dieser Stelle muss
man sagen wer in Kenntnis darum dass
Ermittlungsverfahren läuft solche
Treffen mal strategisch nicht erinnern
kann mal strategisch behauptet ich weiß
gar nicht mehr ganz genau ob und
inwieweit sie stattgefunden haben der
legt einfach die Bank dafür dass ein
solcher Untersuchungsausschuss sich eben
nicht mehr nur mit der Frage von
laufenden Erinnerungslücken oder mit
Formaten was diese Erinnerungslücken
anbetrifft beschäftigen muss sondern
sogar mit der Frage Einflussnahme
Möglichkeit der Vertuschung am Ende
sogar dafür dass Beihilfe geleistet wird
zur Frage einer Steuerhinterziehung in
Höhe von 90 Millionen Euro wenn das kein
Grund ist für einen
Untersuchungsausschuss dann weiß ich
auch nicht mehr
Michael Frieser war das hier in der
Debatte zu einem Untersuchungsausschuss
den die Unionsfraktion hier
einrichten lassen möchte das kann sie
formal denn ein Viertel der Mitglieder
des Deutschen Bundestages muss dafür
stimmen dass so ein
Untersuchungsausschuss eingesetzt wird
und über diese nötige Stimmenzahl
verfügte die Unionsfraktion trotzdem
wird hier dieser
Antrag erst einmal in den entsprechenden
Ausschüsse überwiesen und dann noch mal
im Plenum hier beraten und dann
abgestimmt aber wie gesagt da die
unionsfraktionen die nötige Stärke dafür
hat können wir davon ausgehen dass sie
auch dafür stimmen wird denn am Dienstag
hat die Fraktion schon bei ihrer Sitzung
einstimmig für eine solche Einsetzung
gestimmt